i would like to say a few words about
stan lee who is stan lee of course the
great
create co-creator i should say of uh
marvel comics and the reason stan lee is
so important to me a lot of little boys
used to uh play sports a lot of little
boys
used to sit there and uh hang out with
their dads and learn
i don't know learn things from them uh
stan lee was like my dad because
uh well he was my imaginary dad because
i read all his comic books growing up
well what was different about his
superheroes
about who's stan lee well i'll get to
that robin how dare you interrupt my
soliloquy
but stan lee was amazing because when
you list the characters he either
created co-created however you want to
put it you got spider-man x-men
incredible hulk
iron man fantastic four black panther
thor daredevil
doctor strange ant-man uh who else i
mean a million of them
those characters when you add it all up
as of current day
22 billion dollars have been generated
off of his
productivity he brought characters that
were a little bit deeper at the time
when
marvel came out these guys were a little
bit more
let's say real you know superman was so
unreal he had no problems
yeah these guys had usual human
yeah like spiderman was a boy who was
really unpopular and a nerd and he knew
science and and you know girls couldn't
really look at him then he becomes
spider-man and
he's still conflicted and his aunt is
mad and you know
there was a uh an adult quality to some
of the writing
anyway i pulled a couple of clips if
you'd like to hear this is stanley
talking to larry king uh here's how he
came up with the spider-man character
the thing with the superhero that you
have to get is a unique superpower
well we already had somebody who was the
strongest guy in the world somebody who
could fly and so forth i was thinking
what else is left
i was sitting and i saw a fly crawling
on the wall and i said wow
suppose a person had the power to stick
to a wall like an
insect so i was often running and i
thought what do i call them
i tried mosquito man that didn't have
any glamour
insect man that was even worse and i got
to spider-man
it sounded mysterious and dramatic
and low a legend was born there he is
that's
the man yeah i remember the spider-man
cartoon in the
in the 60s yeah did you know i didn't
know this
the ramones covered the spider-man song
no i didn't yeah
[Applause]
where joey could sing i was gonna say
this should have been the theme
no kidding so when stan lee was about 85
years old
or 80 years old somewhere in that range
he uh called into our show
would a comic called radioactive jew go
over
because uh i have an idea you can work
with any title what about that
listen when you stop wasting time on the
radio for the pittance that they pay you
when you want to make real money
i want you to call me when when millions
of people aren't listening
you and i will sit down and we'll come
up with something
that will really make you think bro i'd
love it let me tell you how about this
incredible shrinking gynecologist when i
was a kid if you told me stan lee would
talk to me
and even joke around about making a
movie i mean i would have
i would have shipped my pants i shot my
pants anyway but
you know and then i thought he was just
you know [ __ ] around but then what
ended up happening
and i wish i had a better memory we got
on the phone and
basically stan lee said i'm going to
create
a superhero character for you you're
interested let's team up
let's write a movie together i've got
some ideas
i want to tell you about but it's just
one of those things that i
never went on with but he was so nice on
the phone
and so open to my ideas and i had
several ideas you know me i'm i'm i'm
full of them i'm full of ideas
anyway stan lee rest in peace i love you
pal